[Music]
what are you most looking forward to
about being married
I just took Mary to my best friend that
you know I've gotten a lot of advice
about how it is gonna feel different and
I think what's special about that is
it's like it's like you're dating again
it's a new spark not that we need it but
the point is is it's kind of fun change
honestly he's the best
and he's my my biggest supporter and
he's my rock and I mean he's the best
person I know well Sasha Pieterse ax can
stop dreaming about her big day because
she's now officially married the Pretty
Little Liars star weds longtime
boyfriend Hudson Schaefer in Ireland and
et has exclusive details from the big
day why'd you choose that destination um
it's one of our favorite places it's
beautiful most of my family's in South
Africa so it's a good meeting point and
yeah I'm gonna have a big reception here
so that everybody I make it but it's
it's really it's family it's yes okay
all family there are you guys praying
your own vows we're gonna do it a little
bit differently um my best friend is
marrying us and we we've written our own
set vows and then we're going to do our
own written vows personally with just a
videographer just the two of us so that
it's yeah it's a little bit more
personal so I'm excited about that we
were talking about the dress earlier are
you going like classic traditional
princess sexy was I the original dress
that I had in my mind was actually
really sexy which I loved and then I
ended up seeing this something
completely opposite it was like this
ball gown and it was off the shoulders
and it was beautiful and that's actually
where I went and I was kind of like its
location like if I'm gonna do a princess
dress that's where I'm gonna do yes so
it's um it's kind of modern kind of
princess and I mean this train is just
it's excessive yeah who's gonna cry
first you or Hudson probably you
probably me yeah emotional emotional too
though I think as soon as I think it's
as you cry no cry yeah my best friend
for a year longer than I've known Hudson
and he's known my best friend a year
longer
he's known me okay and I have a feeling
she's gonna cry first which will make
both of you yeah yeah it'll be the three
of us crying all crying together
I am I have it says a bad word in it so
I can't say it online but it's it says
keep your together
it's a hankerchief and then everybody
else has really nice pretty thing well
there's the mind like they can together
and they love the feeling that I will
definitely need